back to this
this contingency plan yeah i want to
talk here's more yeah well here's more i
want to play this for you peter king
with troy vince sent the executive ep of
football operations on the possibility
that there are extra
games in the wild card round that monday
night could be a spot where games get
dropped uh here they are
this year
if
this is passed
to have eight games on wildcard weekend
we were all in peter but that's the
beauty of it i kind of like it different
but yeah the no wild card weekend you
going one is one is rolling no buys
you coming right off the regular season
you don't have extra rest everybody's
banged up it's you you gotta rock
yeah um
i'm sure this is way way way too early
that wild card weekend could you see
a chance
that one of those eight games
or more might be played on monday night
i think all things are on the table
very possible
yeah and look you've got to figure out
where to put these extra games and why
not park them in prime time the only
challenge is
you're reducing the recovery that's
that's that's what i don't know the
teams that play on monday night you have
to almost we almost have to do is
and i've been a proponent of maximizing
the prime time windows but you you take
that team that plays on monday night and
you guarantee them the latest possible
game the following week or you just make
monday night part of the playoff
experience i think that's what you do
monday night you know right but the
thing is you you're always tied to a
team that plays that first monday night
because whoever wins the first monday
night
plays the next monday night in the
divisional round and whoever wins that
game plays the next monday night in the
championship round and i've been saying
for years sunday night monday night
that's the way they should handle the
conference championship games especially
with two weeks between the conference
championships in the super bowl now this
year who knows if they'll be two weeks
or not because here's the thing once we
get the regular season in
i'm hoping they're gonna have home
market bubbles for the postseason
because it's not like there's a lot of
flexibility to delay playoff weekends if
a team
is ravaged by the virus
and guys just can't play or there aren't
enough players to play or whatever the
case may be that causes the nfl to pull
the plug
uh you know there isn't a whole lot of
flexibility to say well we're gonna have
to postpone the divisional round for a
week now uh you can't just postpone one
game yeah well you know we're going to
play three of the four division around
games we'll make the other one up next
week and then you've got two more weeks
in between those games and it's just
it's a mess potentially so just just
getting through the regular season is
only part of the battle they still need
to keep this thing under control to get
through the post well i know and one of
the owners going to meet about that you
know that that would be something i'd
want to know too i mean at what point
are they going to start discussing and
play off bubbles for these teams because
i would think again that's going to have
to be something that's going to be
you know discussed between the nfl the
nfl pa
and
making some sort of deal there to make
sure that you know the entity of the
playoffs is protected so i mean uh i i
would i'm shocked actually that wasn't
part of this meeting in general maybe it
was maybe we didn't hear about it well
but this is something that the union
definitely would have to agree to yeah
the unions resisted and i think there's
a belief chris that
for the teams that get to the post
season
you don't need to have a mandatory home
market bubble that it's going to be a
hell of a lot easier to convince all
players coaches and essential staff
to explain to their family members look
we've got through the holidays yeah okay
right right the season doesn't end until
after january 1 this year yep
i'm going to stay in the hotel yeah
until this is all over right uh it may
be three weeks it may be one week it may
be four weeks but we're pursuing a
championship we're trying to build a
legacy there's more money at play higher
profile games you know if i'm going to
be a free agent after the season i'm
playing in front of a large audience of
teams that are sitting at home watching
me play for all those reasons i think
you'll see more and more guys
and then you reach a critical mass where
if enough of them are staying in the
hotel voluntarily they're all going to
stay in the volunteer yeah
you're right i mean you know if the the
green bay packers see aaron rodgers and
devonte adams and you know preston and
zadaria smith see them staying in a
hotel
most likely the rest of the team will
follow and just go okay that's what
we're gonna do i mean there's no doubt
about that you know uh the other thing
you know the i don't know if i love the
monday night football thing i hope that
doesn't happen but i don't know is there
any other way to
orchestrate the weekend with that many
games i mean that i guess that's the
really the big question because i don't
want to see a team play you know i i
like what you said as far as the monday
yeah and then it has to be the next
monday and then it'll have to be one
more monday after that certainly
but
i i mean yeah i don't want to see a
playoff team
at a disadvantage with a short week
against another team who you know maybe
had a first round first round but i
don't know it wouldn't have be a case in
this right but i didn't have the short
week i don't want to see that i want to
see best football you know at its best
teams getting to prepare do all that we
saw a game like this a few years ago
where the chiefs uh and pittsburgh got
delayed and then we oh the chiefs the
the the chiefs lost to pittsburgh
pittsburgh goes to new england in a
short week and they looked like crap
they they were
outplayed it was just it was just
delayed from afternoon to evening it
wasn't delayed by a day but but i think
no no it was just from from morning to
evening there was an ice storm uh in
kansas city and it ended up being a
prime time game when it was supposed to
be played maybe at one o'clock that day
or at four o'clock but but
the the every year
i don't know that it happens every
single year but there's always that
potential that someone who plays on the
sunday of wild card weekend yes
play the following saturday
against uh somebody who's been off for
two weeks you get six days to prepare
for a team that's had a 14-day or a
13-day break as the case may be so i'm
fine with one day the problem is you
know you can't you can't do monday
saturday it would at the latest that
team would have to be guaranteed a
sunday game if you play on monday night
but you've got eight windows now that
you've got to find on saturday and
sunday if you're not going to use did
you do it could you do it could you do
it like you know in an 11 30 kickoff a
three o'clock kickoff a seven o'clock
kickoff and a ten o'clock i mean i'm
just throwing stuff out there i just
been thinking about it i know i love
hearing the east coast i love the london
games when they come on at 9 30 in the
morning here i mean that's awesome i do
love it i know that's not fair to like
the west coast but can they can we find
some balance to squeeze them all in i
mean that could be a great day of
football i would love that
it depends on where the games are going
to be right you're not going to play a
new york game
at 10 o'clock at night no and you're not
going to play a west coast game at what
would be 6 30 in the morning if that's
when you would start equivalent to when
those london games begin but it's it's
easy to have three windows
on a saturday or a sunday it becomes
much more difficult to add in that
window which is what which is what the
nfl would be trying to do but i guess
what you would do
if you could pull it off you do a
morning game you do ten one four and
eight right right but who's going to
watch that game at ten who's i don't
know it's a playoff game and it's on tv
i mean we will the west coast
a little yeah i know but if they can get
to monday night i think you find a way
to get to monday night and then you
guarantee that the winner of the monday
night game plays the following sunday
you don't have to go monday monday
monday through the playoffs you can do
monday sunday yeah especially for this
one year you can say to a team you're
playing monday night and then you're
playing the following sunday in the late
window period that's it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports